What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity
For this challenge episode we took your ideas from Instagram
and we literally got thousands of requests
Let's see what we got!
It's time to tie these two together
There is 70% of you guys who still haven't subscribed
so remember to do that now!
Gotta move!
I don't like this at all!
That hurt!
Felt like my hand came off!
Let's try to play with chopsticks
Ooh three in a row!
Now you're gonna miss
Three tries
This is good practice for when I'm going to
eat Chinese food next
I'm just gonna be there like...
Can you pass me the salt? Thanks!
Let's go for the double around the net
That's just where you're aiming for!
Let's try out the triangle ball
This seems like an interesting idea!
Well let's see how many shots we can get
Maybe three. One for each ball!
Roller!
What a serve!
That is a good serve
I can't believe the ball didn't break!
That was a cool idea but it didn't
really quite work out as we were hoping
No it didn't
But remember to subscribe
and watch our previous episodes there
Until next time!